phototropism in plants is a response in
which a plant chute grows toward a light
source the results of five different
experimental treatments from classic
investigations of phototropism are shown
above
part a gives support for the claim that
the cells located in the tip of the
plant shoot
give support for the claim that the the
cells located in the tip of the plant
chute detect the light by comparing the
results from treatment group one with
the results from treatment group 2 and
treatment group 3 so we want to compare
these first
first three treatment groups and you see
when you have an all unaltered tip that
the whole plant is going to bend in the
direction of the light when you remove
the tip it no longer bends in the in the
in the direction of the light or if you
were to cover the tip with some type of
an opaque cap so the light can't go
through it it's still not going to bend
so this is pretty good evidence that
there's some there's something about the
tip of the plant that allows the
phototropism to occur it allows the
plant
to know which direction the light is and
and then makes and then somehow causes
it to bend in that direction
so i'll just write that down
give support for the claim
so
we can say that phototropism
phototropism
only occurred
when
there
is
a an
unaltered tip
unaltered
tip
that has access to the light that has
access
to light
no bending occurred
no
bending
occurred
when
either
the tip was removed
the tip
was removed
that was
that was treatment
two
so
treatment
treatment two
or
the
tip
was
tip had an opaque cover the tip
had
an
opaque
cover that was
treatment
three
so that's all there is to it it only
occurred when there was an alt-altered
tip so that was treatment one that has
access to light no betting occurred when
either the tip was removed and this one
and treatment two or treatment three so
it's a pretty good indication that you
need that tip and it needs to have
access to the light something about the
tip
lets the plant know what direction to
start bending in all right let's do part
b now
part b
in treatment groups four and five so
that's these two treatment groups right
over here the tips of the plants are
removed and placed back onto the chute
on either a permeable or impermeable
barrier using the results from treatment
groups four and five describe two
additional characteristics of the
phototropism response
well when when the tip was placed on top
of a permanent permeable barrier the
phototropism still happens the the plant
still bends so even though the the tip
is disconnected
because this barrier is permeable the
tip must be able to
sense the light and release some type of
substance or hormone or chemical or
something that's able to go through this
permeable permeable barrier
some type of substance that goes through
this permeable barrier and somehow
signals to the rest of the plant to bend
in the right direction because when you
put an impermeable barrier right over
here the the tip might be trying to
release those same substances but they
can't get through and so the rest of the
plant doesn't know to bend or in what
direction to bend so we could say
we could say
tip
must
release
some
type
of hormone
hormone
i say chemical
chemical
that
signals
to
rest
of plant
to bend to bend
and in which direction
which
direction
we know this
because
only
the or only like a treatment for
only treatment for
treatment for
permeable barrier
and i'll say where the where the barrier
is permeable to that substance
where
the barrier
is permeable
permeable
to that substance
that substance
we know this because only treatment four
where the barriers permeable to the
substance
shows
shows phototropism
phototropism
not
treatment
five
we know this we could say because of the
two
of
four
and five only treatment four where the
barrier is permeable to that substance
shows trope tropism phototropism that's
the only explanation here that it's not
doing it through somehow doing it
through radio waves or releasing
substances that somehow float in the air
to the rest of the plant that somehow
some type of substance is going through
through directly from the the tip to the
rest of the plant and when you block it
it's not able to send those chemical
signals that's that's the best that's
the best explanation uh that i can think
of for this behavior that we see between
treatments 4 and 5.